oui
bonsoir à tous et bruno le maire est
l'invité de preuves par 3 après avoir
passé de longues heures à arpenter les
allées du salon de l'agriculture où nous
sommes bruno le maire bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous vous avez été
ministre de ce secteur que vous
connaissez bien vous multipliez aussi
bien sûr ici les échanges directs avec
les français alors êtes-vous en campagne
permanente vous le dirai tout à l'heure
à nadège pull jacques qui suit l'ump
pour l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire pour preuve par trois et puis
bien sûr nous aborderons les dossiers
agricoles parfois très polémique avec
perrine tarneaud de public sénat d'abord
d'autres grands sujets de l'actualité
cette nuit paris survolée par des drones
l'une française enlevée au yémen et puis
françois hollande qui est contraint de
jouer au médiateur entre les
représentants des communautés juive et
musulmane
or on l'a bien vu ces dernières semaines
le climat d'union nationale s'est
volatilisé est-ce qu'ils n'obligent pas
aujourd'hui tous les responsables de
droite du centre de gauche à renouer
avec lui
moi je crois que la france aujourd'hui
il a besoin vente ou de paix de
conciliation et d'autorité les trois la
paix la conciliation ça veut dire le
respect entre les communautés il ya
différentes communautés religieuses en
france elles doivent se respecter
mutuellement l'autorité c'est le strict
respect des principes républicains
l'état est là pour garantir la liberté
de culte il est là aussi pour garantir
la liberté de ceux qui ne croient en
aucun culte et de croix en rien c'est
parfaitement légitime et c'est le rôle
de leader dans le fils je disais entre
les représentants du crif et du cfcm dis
moi j'aimerais que les représentants des
cultes puissent s'entendre eux mêmes
sans qu'il y ait d'intervention de
l'état moi je pense que le rôle de
l'état aujourd'hui n'est pas
d'interférer avec les religions il n'est
pas d'organiser les religions à la place
des religions il est de garantir le
strict respect des principes
républicains françois hollande
outrepasse son rôle j'estime que ce
n'est pas le rôle de l'état de jouer les
monsieur bons offices entre différents
cultes j'estime que le rôle de l'état
c'est garantir le respect des principes
républicains de rappeler une règle
simple en république ce sont les
religions qui se soumettent à la
république ce n'est pas la république
qui se soumet aux religions et il y à
cette polémique donc après les propos du
président du crif projet kerman qui a
fait porter donc la responsabilité des
actes antisémites sur des jeunes
musulmans il a dit que c'était vraiment
une infime minorité est-ce que vous avez
été choqué par les propos du président
du crif je crois que la france a moins
besoin que jamais de polémiques sur des
sujets aussi sensibles elle a besoin de
principe les principes républicains que
j'ai rappelé l'état est là pour garantir
de la liberté des cultes de ceux qui ne
croient pas une île a pas là pour
interférer avec la vie des religions il
est là pour garantir aussi le respect de
chacun de ces cultes il ya aujourd'hui
en france que j'appelle un antisémitisme
chronique qui va de l'injure de
l'insultent de la menace verbale de la
menace dans le regard jusqu'à
détérioration des lieux de culte la
profanation des lieux de culte jusqu'à
des attentats comme celui de
l'hypermarché cacher dramatique que nous
avons connu il ya quelques semaines cet
antisémitisme chronique doit être
combattue à la racine la racine c'est
l'éducation et c'est pour cela que je
fais du combat pour l'éducation le
combat prioritaire aujourd'hui on fait
alors donc françois hollande a évoqué la
lèpre de l'antisémitisme qui revient
dans notre pays il ya un autre mot qui a
marqué c'est celui utilisé par le
premier ministre manuel valls qui a
évoqué l'islamo fascisme est ce que vous
leur prendriez là à votre compte je
pense qu'on a aucun intérêt à exagérer
les mots qu'on emploie
je pense que ce sont les actions qui
doivent être fortes et décisif et pas
les mots qui doivent être exagéré quand
j'entends manuel valls parler par
exemple d'apartheid en france je pense
que c'est une faute une vraie faute
politique parce que ça revient en
quelque sorte à nous expliquer que ce
d'état français qui est responsable de
ce qui se pense aujourd'hui d'un certain
nombre de quartiers ça n'est pas le cas
parler d'islam au fascisme c'est
dissimuler la réalité de la menace
islamiste qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur
notre pays beaujolais pas clairement la
désigner cette menace certaines mêmes
parlent d'eux du
nazislamisme mais je pense la force de
forcer les mots que l'on emploie on ne
prend plus les décisions nécessaires
pour combattre avec efficacité
l'islamisme radical qui est une menace
pour nous touche en france oui et quitte
une menace à l'extérieur de nos fonds
alors justement je vais vous dire très
simplement ma conception de la politique
c'est des mots qui soit peut-être plus
mesuré et des actes qu'ils soient
beaucoup plus fort ben voyons les
socialismes aujourd'hui c'est l'inversé
remo qui sont outrés essais des actes
qui ne sont pas à la hauteur a cassé le
dernier c'est quand même l'engagement du
porte avions charles de gaulle dans la
lutte contre le groupe etat islamique
voilà un acte fort qui
ramène diront certains peut-être ne sais
pas vous la france au rang de puissance
qui veut compter tout ce qui est bon les
gens militaire bien sûr que j'accorde et
j'approuve toutes les interventions
militaires qui sont conduites
actuellement contre dèche l'état
islamique qui étend son emprise de
l'irak à la syrie en passant par le
yémen et maintenant la libye la libye
est pour moi un sujet de préoccupation
majeur j'ai échangé avec le secrétaire
général des nations unies à new york et
quelques heures sur ce sujet là et j'ai
bien vu que pour toutes les autorités
internationales aujourd'hui la libye et
la menace numéro un conclusion pour vos
bruno le maire est ce qu'il faut
intervenir à ce que la france doit
s'engager en libye également je pense
qu'il faudra un moment ou un autre une
intervention militaire en libye je crois
simplement que la france n'a pas à
prendre la tête de quelques coalition
que ce soit dans certains avancions
possible en libye pourquoi d'abord parce
que la france ne peut pas être à la fois
au four et au moulin peut pas à la fois
être mali présente en irak et en même
temps s'occuper de la libye c'est à
d'autres pays de prendre la tête d'une
coalition pour ramener l'ordre en libye
en deuxième lieu je souhaite que le
maximum d'états musulmans soient
impliqués dans cette lutte en libye
qu'on puisse pas dire que c'est une
guerre de civilisation ya pas de guerre
de civilisation qui a d'un côté notre
civilisation la civilisation européenne
la civilisation occidentale et de
l'autre un état dictatorial qui
s'appelle d'esch et qui n'a parents de
civilisation donc je souhaite en
deuxième lieu simone d'état musulmans
puissent être impliqués dans cette lutte
contre des juges pour montrer que ce
n'est pas une guerre de civilisation
européenne de valeurs et de principes
enfin troisième mieux je souhaite
effectivement que d'autres pays
européens prennent une partie du fardeau
je trouve aujourd'hui que les états
européens ne sont pas suffisamment
présents sur le sol à côté de nos
troupes pour lutter contre l'islamisme
ans alors il y à une renaissance
angleterre en ce moment vous allez
pouvoir en juger c'est le couple franco
allemand avec angela merkel qui
apprécient comme jamais dit on désormais
françois hollande peut-être que ça vous
fait plaisir bruno le maire en tous les
cas on les a sentis très actif
évidemment sur l'ukraine est ce qu'ils
ont eu raison selon vous de faire
confiance à vladimir poutine quand on
voit comment ça se passe sur le terrain
après les accords de minsk ces accords
je le dis depuis le début ce sont des
accords en trompe l'oeil et
malheureusement ce sont d accord fragile
donc ce qu'il faudra c'est continuer à
mettre la pression sur des lumières
poutine jour après jour semaine après
semaine elle revient vent tourne
toujours le pilot les rois comme enfin
l'ukraine continuer à maintenir la
pression économique continuer à aider
les ukrainiens civilement et
certainement pas militairement pour
montrer que l'europe et du côté de
l'état ukrainien prête à lui apporter
une aide civile économique pour tenir
bon face à la russie donc il faut
toujours avoir un discours de fermeté
avec le président russe ella seul
langage que vladimir poutine peut
comprendre c'est un langage de dialogue
mais la libère poutine alors qu'elle est
de françois hollande et de fermeté les
deux à l'affront et ne pensons pas une
seconde qu'une signature d'un accord
faisant respecter l'accord de minsk qui
a été à peine sec pourra tenir très
longtemps si nous ne maintenons pas
cette politique d'engagement mêlant le
dialogue et la fermeté des deux niveaux
foot alors on va parler de l'ump dans un
instant va dire un mot sur le parti
socialiste qui ce soir a froncé frondeur
et qui sont qualifiés comme des
irresponsables et d immature par manuel
valls vous qui avez commenté le les
choix linguistiques de l'exécutif reno
lemaire est ce que pour vous le ps est
définitivement fracturé il est surtout
définitivement décrédibilisée le parti
socialiste les socialistes ne parlent
plus qu'aux socialistes il ne parle plus
aux français les socialistes s'occupent
plus que des socialistes ne s'occupe
plus des français les socialistes ne
voit plus que les socialistes il ne voit
plus les français
moi je souhaite que cette majorité
prennent conscience la difficulté que
vivent aujourd'hui une majorité de
français prennent conscience de son
échec en matière de lutte contre le
chômage prenne conscience de la colère
qui gronde que l'on voit ici dans nos
campagnes prennent conscience du
désarroi des populations qui habitent
dans les zones rurales et arrête avec
cette politique ireep politicienne qui
n'intéresse personne est là le ps est un
texte que vous avez cliqué la loi macron
et le premier ministre annonce déjà de
nouveaux textes et elle fait acte
d'autorité en mettant le canada ne le
croyait capable à
qui va-t-on faire croire que la loi
macron va changer quoi que ce soit à la
vie des français est celle qui sera la
disette on faire croire que la loi
macron va permettre de lutter contre le
chômage entre pays de donner des emplois
aux jeunes de données emploi tous et
comptait licencier de réindustrialiser
le pays de nous permettre de retrouver
un élan de puissance économique le
gouvernement actuel la majorité actuelle
n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux est
empêtrée dans des querelles intestines
qui n'intéresse pas les français mettez
vous à la place des français qui voient
manuel valls en lutte contre les
frondeurs les fondeurs en lutte contre
françois hollande le 49-3 qui signe la
fin de la majorité
car lorsque vous mettez le 49-3 c'est
qu'il ya divorce entre l'exécutif et la
majorité manuel real n'est pas le
premier à l'utiliser et lui présente
année je vais enseigner la preuve ce
sont de grands c'est bruno l'hommage et
une certaine expérience sur le sujet
puisque j'étais directeur de cabinet du
dernier premier ministre de droite
qu'emile 49 3 alors quand on met le 49-3
on croit qu'on fait un acte d'autorité
c'est une preuve de faiblesse le 49 3
est une preuve de faiblesse c'est la
preuve que l'exécutif ne tient plus sa
majorité c'est la preuve tout simplement
que l'exécutif françois hollande et
manuel valls en tête non plus les moyens
de gouverner voilà la réalité de la
situation actuelle un pays qui
s'effondre économiquement des français
qui souffre un chômage qui n'a jamais
été aussi élevé une incapacité du
gouvernement du président la république
apporter des réponses et de l'autre côté
une majorité totalement éclatée entre
l'exécutif et le parlement à rien je
trouve ça profondément préoccupant
arnaud montebourg a pronostiqué huit
cent mille chômeurs de plus à la fin du
quinquennat avec le front national
présent au second tour est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec l'ancien ministre du
redressement productif je pense qu'il ya
une certaine joie mauvaise comme on dit
chez arnaud montebourg qui a été expulsé
du gouvernement a parié sur
l'augmentation du nombre de chômeurs moi
mon rôle de responsable politique c'est
de dire tout simplement aux français que
si nous voulons enfin faire baisser le
chômage dans notre pays il faut sortir
du traitement social du chômage sur
lequel nous vivons depuis 40 ans qui est
un échec total et aller vers un
traitement économique il faut arrêter de
donner des chèques à tout le monde et se
battent pour leur donner un emploi il
faut modifier l'indemnisation du chômage
comme je le réclame depuis maintenant
quatre ans qu'on réduise la durée ce que
disait c'est ce que des avantages on va
voir s'il va porter la durée
d'indemnisation du chômage et que l'on
accompagne davantage des chômeurs dès le
premier jour du chômage que l'on mette
en place un nouveau contrat de travail
plus simple plus souple qu'on simplifie
le droit du travail j'ai proposé un
nouveau code du travail 250 pages
répondre aux attentes des pme des dpe
des artisans des commerçants et c'est
tout ça qui font affaire ça fait plus de
deux ans que françois hollande est au
pouvoir qu'est-ce qu'il attend alors une
dernière question dans cette première
partie de preuves par 3 ici nous sommes
au salon de l'agriculture concernant la
grèce qui finalement va accepte le
programme de réformes imposées par la
zone euro bruno le maire est ce que
c'est une défaite en rase campagne pour
le moment syriza selon vous
d'illusions gauchistes aura duré
quelques jours
chacun savait que c'était une illusion
et si cette politique dont on ne veut
plus on se fait élire sur un projet et
on fait le contraire trois semaines
après moi je veux dire des choses vraies
aux français je préfère dire clairement
ce que sera notre projet ce que seront
nos décisions plutôt de faire comme si
prat ce qui promet monts et merveilles
qui pense qu'on pourra s'exonérer de ses
responsabilités ne pas rembourser sa
dette augmenter les salaires des
fonctionnaires tout ça mais dès qu'il
s'agit de son ascension détenir de
l'aider à se certainement pas non je
n'ai pas envie de soutenir un programme
qui est un mensonge depuis le début
comme le programme de françois hollande
était un mensonge depuis le début le
programme de la gauche andres est un
mensonge depuis le début ne fera que
nourrir davantage les extrêmes en grèce
quand on ment des extrêmes montrent moi
je suis pour un langage de vérité qui
montre la réalité des problèmes et que
c'est d'apporter les solutions les plus
crédibles si vous êtes un peu doper
encore un peu plus peut-être dans votre
passage sur l'âge et la pression j'étais
la martinique je passais la martinique
16 est un bon choix alors on va parler
de votre cheminement pas seulement ici
dans les allées du salon bruno le maire
veut y compris un récent article du
point vous concernant été titré attrape
moi si tu peux alors vous allez dire
dans un instant à nadège peljak d'une
agence france presse notre partenaire et
qui donc est à vos trousses d'abord ce
reportage sur vos pas signé jérôme
rabier
c'est une petite entreprise qui ne
connaît pas la crise montée il y a deux
ans et demi le micro parti de bruno le
maire est devenue une véritable écurie
qui compte à droite fort de 30 % des
voix lors de l'élection à la présidence
de l'ump bruno le maire compte bien
capitaliser
je suis heureux pour ce que nous portons
le renouveau qui est un engagement qui
nous dépasse et un engagement qui ne
fait que commencer quatre salariés
permanents seulement mais un réseau de
militants présents dans tous les
départements constitué au gré de sa
centaine de déplacements en france et
qu'il faut désormais renforcée si jamais
bruno le maire se lance pour la primaire
de 2016 c'est pas en 2016 à l'échéance
des primaires s'il prend cette décision
qui fera se réveiller tout d'un pont en
disant oh la la qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
- la responsabilité elle est de
maintenir et de mettre en place une
armée de militants enthousiastes engagé
qui sont prêts et qu'ils seront prêts le
si
d'aventuré bruno le maire décide de
partir
sa décision n'est pas encore connue mais
histoire de ne pas insulter l'avenir il
a imposé un de ses proches le député
thierry solère à la tête du comité
chargé d'organiser les primaires ump et
lui ne cache pas sa volonté moi j'espère
que bruno très bien il sera candidat aux
primaires le moment venu je suis moi
chargé à l'ump de avec d'autres de
travailler à la règle du jeu pour c'est
pour ces primaires je sais juste par
expérience que c'est pas parce qu'on a
dit qu'on serait candidat aux primaires
on le sera vraiment et c'est pas parce
qu'on l'a pas encore dit qu'on ne le
sera pas le moment venu bruno le maire
cherche désormais à passer du statut
d'outsider de l'ump à présidentiable
preuve en est ses déplacements à
l'étranger comme à new york la semaine
dernière où il a pu rencontrer ban ki
moon le secrétaire général de l'onu mais
son ascension provoque aussi de
nouvelles inimitiés comme la semaine
passée où il s'est fait battre en
interne à l'ump pour être chef de file
lors des régionales de décembre en
normandie et même l'opposition fait
désormais une cible de choix toute une
génération nouvelle d'ailleurs avec
monsieur wauquiez monsieur le maire
d'autres jeunes qui est so sur une
radicalisation de droite quelquefois en
essayant d'aller frapper des idées sur
l'extrême droite sans échéances
électorales personnelles cette année
bruno le maire continue de tisser sa
toile son réseau et alimenter son projet
pour cela il reprend son tour de france
qui lui avait réussi lors de la campagne
interne à l'ump voilà et ce tour de
france qui fait halte aujourd'hui au
salon d'aviculture avec nadja qui nous
rejoint notre concert de la fp vos
questions à bruno le maire bonjour
monsieur le maire est bien qu'on a vu
dans le petit sujet que certains ont
l'air de douter vous soyez candidat à la
primaire ajout pose la question tout de
go serez vous oui ou non candidat à la
primaire ump
sauver nadège pull jacques
il ya une très belle expression
italienne qui dit qui va piano va sano
chaque chose en son temps très bien vous
avez le temps assez court comme réponse
est un peu court mais je sais que je ne
tiendrai rien d'autre pour l'instant
donc autant ces concepts explique alain
elle vous a passé la journée donc on l'a
dit au salon de l'agriculture n'était
pas le seul à y avait également alain
juppé il y avait ma vie' bertrand demain
nicolas sarkozy sera là on a quand même
l'impression que le salon de
l'agriculture c'est un passage obligé
pour les futurs candidats vous serez pas
la banque à la primaire de l'ump est un
indice supplémentaire
c'est surtout un passage obligé pour un
ancien ministre de l'agriculture a pu me
permettre j'ai été trois ans ministres
d'agriculture j'ai un attachement très
profond pour le monde paysan je veux les
défendre et donc je suis très heureux de
passer plusieurs heures au son
agriculture pour écouter les paysans
comprendre leurs difficultés s'il y
apporter des réponses j'entendais
monsieur le foll tout à l'heure qui me
reprochaient de me rapprocher de
l'extrême droite moi il me fait rire
monsieur le foll il ne prend aucune des
décisions nécessaires pour répondre aux
attentes des agriculteurs pour alléger
leurs difficultés pour leur permettre de
vivre mieux il fait objectivement faute
de résultats dans les campagnes monter
le front national dans les campagnes
mais nous reproche en chine savez il
nous reproche ensuite de faire monter le
front national je pense que ce qui fait
monter le front national c'est les
échecs des socialistes sur le terrain
mais pour la droite thomas revenir à la
droite est ce que vous vous avez encore
parlées au monde rural je l'espère et je
crois qu'on a des choix effectivement
clair à faire et j'ai eu le sentiment
pendant toutes ces heures que j'ai passé
au salon de l'agriculture qu'il fallait
que nous soyons que claire dans nos
propositions pour le monde rural les
agriculteurs ont des difficultés sur
l'application des normes
environnementales gaillon de courage de
dire qu'il faudra repousser la mise en
place de certaines règles
environnementales qui sont aujourd'hui
trop lourd trop complexe pour les
agriculteurs que les deux écoles on va
les aborder un peu plus tard dans l'est
mais je veux simplement dire
politiquement qu'ils les temps que nous
ayons le courage de dire clairement aux
agriculteurs au monde rural ce que nous
ferons pour nous et on ne pourra pas
pardonnez moi l'expression ménager la
chèvre et le chou il ya un moment donné
il faudra prendre position clairement je
suis du côté des producteurs je veux
défendre les agriculteurs et je
continuerai à tenir cette meilleure vous
avez eu le pouvoir pendant dix ans vous
avez été vous même comme vous le disiez
ministre de l'agriculture de 2009 à 2012
le rappel et qu'est ce que vous avez
fait pendant tout ce temps là parce que
aujourd'hui vous disiez tout à l'heure
la situation des agriculteurs est très
préoccupant
si nous avions répondu à toutes les
attentes de notre électorat nous
n'aurions pas été battu en 2012 et je
vous donne un exemple
aux attentes non en fera suffisamment
non et je le dis moi même comme ancien
ministre de l'agriculture j'ai discuté
avec les représentants de la filière
porcine filière bovine je me suis battu
pour qu'on simplifie le régime des
installations classées c'est à dire ce
qui permet à un exploitant de regrouper
deux exploitations et d'être plus
compétitif on n'a pas réussi à le
simplifier suffisamment c'est notre
propre majorité qui a reculé devant
cette simplification c'est notre propre
majorité qui n'a pas permis aux
agriculteurs de reconstruire une
nouvelle exploitation avec une
autorisation six mois il faut six mois
en allemagne il faut près de deux ans en
france pour obtenir cette autorisation
ne nous étonnons pas
ne nous étonnons pas après qu'il y ait
cette colère sourde dans le monde
agricole il faut que nous prenons des
engagements par exemple ces
installations classées mais sur 50
autres dossiers que la prochaine fois
nous tiendrons parole élevé
et bien ce soit dans le monde rural sera
décisif dans les prochaines élections
les paysans les agriculteurs tous ceux
qui vivent aujourd'hui du monde rural
qui apporte des emplois qu apportent
leur travail leur activité et nous
regarderons de près
je pense qu'ils ne prendront pas des
vessies pour des lanternes alors il n'y
a pas que l'agriculture sur lesquels
vous voulez faire des propositions comme
la compenser par exemple logement pardon
l'ump vers une convention sur le
jugement le 18 mars à laquelle vous
allez peut-être participer françois
fillon de son côté présente ses
propositions sur le logement également
demain matin vous vous préparez votre
projet juppé prépare son projet monsieur
juppé prépare son projet monsieur
bertrand également on a l'impression
qu'il ya beaucoup de chapelles chez vous
est ce qu'il ya un clocher commun vous
me permettez une deuxième expression
populaire abondance de biens ne saurait
nuire c'est très bien fait il sait très
bien non mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que l'ump doit proposer un socle
de projet qui doit être clair avec des
lignes qui doit être forte moi j'ai
proposé des lignes très simple et très
forte un état régalien plus solide avec
une restauration de son autorité des
entreprises libre totalement libre
l'éducation comme projet prioritaire la
construction européenne à 19 le dock à
28 bien que l'ump pose les bases de son
projet est ensuite libre à chaque
candidat déclaré à la primaire que ce
soit françois fillon alain juppé xavier
bertrand d'apporter énormément ça ne me
dérange pas je trouve au même même que
c'est une très bonne chose que tous les
candidats déclarés à la primaire puisse
faire preuve d'initiative d'audace et
proposer des jouets d'éveil de
compétition mais qui compétition c'est
formidable la compétition nous à droite
on serait contre la compétition du
moment que les règles sont claires et
que les règles sont respectées par tout
le monde la compétition est une bonne
chose si la compétition est une
émulation c'est très bien si elle est
une critique systématique de voisins ça
n'est pas le mot vous est fixé des
règles en la matière toujours moi je
veux fixe toujours des règles de
comportement je pense que c'est très
bien les invitons nos concurrents pas
vis-à-vis de mes concurrents je ne
critique jamais personnellement un
concurrent à droite parce que j'estime
que ça n'a absolument aucun sens on est
là effectivement pour voir de
l'émulation pour qu'il y ait compétition
dans les projets dans les idées qu'au
bout du compte on propose le meilleur
pour les français et que ça qui compte
pour moi qu'on est au bout du compte sur
la table le meilleur candidat avec le
meilleur projet pour les français
uniquement et nicolas sarkozy comment
vous le voyez vous voyez comme le patron
pour un parti ou un candidat parmi
d'autres comme le président du parti il
assuré son mail parti les présidents du
parti il rassemble et je crois que c'est
le rôle du président du parti de
rassembler le plus largement possible
actuellement s'il est aussi incarner un
leadership
oui selon il rassemble à charge pour lui
maintenant d'affirmer effectivement un
leadership mais le leadership ne nous y
trompons pas il sera décidé le moment
venu par la primaire donc par les
militants les sympathisants qui se
reconnaissent dans nos idées dans nos
valeurs c'est le choix qu'on a tous fait
un parti avec un président dont la
légitimité est reconnu par tous et
ensuite un candidat à la présidentielle
qui sera désigné par les primaires et
seulement à ce moment-là savez qu'il ya
un sondage bva qui viennent pas de
paraître sur lequel seuls 22% des
français veulent de nicolas sarkozy
comme représentant la droite en 17 ans
fait partie des 22 % ou des 78 %
restants je pense que vous êtes trop
fine observatrice la neige plus jacques
pour à 32 mois les réponses à ce sujet
je vais vous dire très simplement si on
suit les sondages en politique je peux
vous dire on reste chez soi on bouge
plus le petit doigt c'est sa volonté son
intuition qu'il faut suivre sa
détermination je crois que c'est la
seule chose qui compte est que vous
inspire ce chiffre symbolique des
sondages ah oui mais quand même vous
avez une appréciation sur ce chiffre
effectivement que donne la peine de
mort l'important souhaitent voir nicolas
sarkozy quand il est en recul de 11
points par rapport à juillet 2014 il
sort un sondage par jour pour ne pas
dire par heure en revanche je me fais
pas au regard des plus attentifs à
vanter les sondages eh bien je perdrais
mon fils et mon fils c'est de proposer
aux français en les écoutant passant du
temps avec eux quelque chose qui puisse
les convaincre que ya encore un espoir
en politique que la politique peut
vraiment changer les choses qui peut y
avoir de nouvelles pratiques politiques
qui peut y avoir encore du renouveau
dans la vie politique française les
français effectivement ils sont lassés
de voir les mêmes discours les mêmes
visages des mêmes propositions les mêmes
idées les mêmes slogans de droite la
même pratique politique le cumul des
mandats les hauts fonctionnaires qui
vous interdit de la chine allait bien je
suis un candidat je suis un candidat
pour les français pour leur apporter du
renouveau comment est-ce que ce sera dur
à le moment venu vous le verrez bien un
peu de patience mais un autre il ya un
autre pourcentage lui n'est pas un
sondage les 30% mais près de prendre
sans devoir que vous avez obtenus pour
la présidence de l'ump le 29 novembre
dernier
comment est ce que vous faites
capitaliser sur ces voies ça c'est
beaucoup plus important qu'un sondage ce
sont effectivement des voix de français
et moi je ne crois qu'à ça on voit des
français en 2015 je vais continuer comme
je le fais aujourd'hui au ministère au
salon de l'agriculture pardon à circuler
en france avoir des français aller sur
le terrain écouter comprendre proposés
et puis fin 2015 début 2016 je prendrai
une décision mais prenons le temps de
cultiver ce qui a été lancé comme
message par les français de droite à la
fin de l'année 2014
le message a été lancé avec ses près de
30% il est simple nous voulons du
changement nous voulons du rhône et même
de l'électorat de la droite
ce message a été lancé clairement je l'
ai entendu ceux qui me soutiennent l'ont
entendu les députés sénateurs élus
locaux maires qui me soutiennent ont
parfaitement entendu on veut du
renouveau bien faut continuer à le
cultiver en 2015 2015 je veux cultiver
ce score qui m'a été donnée par les
électeurs de droite alors en 2015 et
bientôt il ya des départementales
premier tour 22 mars les sondages
annoncent de bons scores pour le front
national est ce que ça vous inquiète
la menace du front national j'en parle
depuis maintenant trois ans on le voit
sur le terrain l'exaspération un
sentiment d'abandon de délaissement
beaucoup de français sentiment qu'on
n'apporte pas des réponses concrètes à
leur situation et puis la réalité la
réalité c'est que depuis quarante ans
vous pouvez regarder le chômage il n'a
pas beaucoup baissé on a été incapable
d'empêcher la désindustrialisation
on a été incapable d'empêcher la
paupérisation de certains territoires et
bien à nous d'apporter des réponses
suffisamment forte pour combattre le
front national oui le front national est
fort aujourd'hui en france on le sait
tous à partir de là on fait quoi on se
réjouit vous à gauche on arrive à
contrer le front national parce que
reposant sur lyon c'est le visage de
marine le pen ou bien et bien c'est bien
la preuve qu'il faut face au visage de
marine le pen est capable à droite de
proposer de nouveaux visages de nouveaux
discours de nouvelle offre politique et
ça passe aussi par un comportement
politique différent et par des discours
et des propositions les plus clair
possible en cas de second tour c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose bien
sûr ps fn vous faites quoi vous
personnellement le moi je laisse les
électeurs libres de trancher je les fais
dans le doubs et je revendique cette
position c'est le ni-ni c'est pas en
appelant à voter pour les socialistes
que nous feront baisser le front
national c'est une position de combat
que je prends
prenez le comportement politique quand
je vois que certains dans ma famille
politique continue à défendre le cumul
des mandats continuer à cumuler la haute
fonction publique et la vie politique
mais les gens ne comprennent plus cela
ils ne comprennent plus cette attitude
politique donc à nous d'avoir un
comportement politique différent des
propositions fortes c'est la seule
réponse au front national des électeurs
américains en cas de duel on parle du
second tour je voudrais présidentielle
on parle pas d'une élection partielle
est parce qu ailleurs parce qu'ils ont
fait tout le monde se résignent à voir
marine le pen au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle en 2017 jamais
je vous dis bien jamais je ne me
résignerai avoir marine le pen au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2017 si ça arrive
jamais eh bien je refuse de me placer
dans ce cas de figure parce que je ferai
tout pour que ce soit nous qui soyons
qualifiés au deuxième tour peut
élections présidentielles et que ce soit
ma famille politique qui gagne
l'élection présidentielle vous savez des
électeurs du front national depuis ce
matin j'en ai vu ou sur l'airé
culturelle était présent vers vous mais
vers vous en impression que c'est des
gens qui sont des martiens alors les
électeurs du front national ce ne sont
pas des martiens j'ai des gens comme
vous et comme moi qui demande simplement
comme vous et comme moi qui demande
simplement qu'on apporte des réponses à
leurs questions à leurs problèmes à
leurs difficultés si on n'a pas compris
cela aujourd'hui des millions
d'électeurs en france estime que les
responsables politiques n'apporte pas
les réponses
d'ibm aux difficultés qu'ils vivent on
laissera le front national progresser si
on a de la considération de l'écouté de
l'attention pour tous ces français et
que nos réponses sont suffisamment forte
et crédible là on fera baisser le front
national moi je connais pas d'autre
réponse à la montée du front national en
france merci nadège perrine tarneaud de
public sénat va arriver maintenant et on
va ouvrir à nouveau quelques grands
dossiers agricoles et pour la survie de
ce secteur pour notre alimentation aussi
bien évidemment notre sécurité
alimentaire aussi marie brémaud a appris
comme vous le pouls d'une population
inquiète
2014 n'aura pas été une très bonne année
pour les agriculteurs français en cause
une chute drastique des revenus moins
25% tous secteurs confondus
c'est le cas notamment la filière
porcine la france a perdu 3 millions de
porcs en 12 ans pendant que l'allemagne
en gagnait 2,17 millions le président
d'inaporc pointe du doigt les inégalités
de traitement au sein même de l'union
européenne
concernant
le coût du travail n'est pas que vous
savez que nos collègues européens
néerlandais danois ont une dérogation à
la réglementation sur l'épandage la zot
qui est à 250 unités
par hectare et par an et nous sommes à
140 unités donc la règle
environnementale elle n'est pas du tout
appliquée de la même manière dans les
différents états européens et nous je
vous répète nous sommes les meilleurs
élèves de la classe et c'est un handicap
majeur pour nous parce que ça suppose
effectivement des surcoûts moderniser
les exploitations augmenter les
rendements ne pas avoir peur du mot
rentabilité en clair il faut faire
évoluer le modèle agricole français le
monde agricole a un peu souffert à
l'époque ne pas se considérer comme
étant de véritables entreprises alors
effectivement des petites tpe ou pme
mais qui ont tout leur savoir faire dans
notre secteur c'est quand même plus de
700 mille emplois dans le monde des
fruits et légumes 7 700 mille emplois et
on pèse 15 milliards d'euros au niveau
de la consommation donc c'est quand même
des chiffres qui parlent et je pense
qu'il faut se considérer beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui on le voit d'ailleurs comme
une véritable entreprise avec ces
thématiques le sort de développement à
l'étranger des difficultés mais un
énorme potentiel la france reste la
première puissance agricole d'europe un
leadership de plus en plus contesté une
vulnérabilité dont sans avoir conscience
le chef de l'état soulagé un certain
nombre de situations parce que les
prions
bc d'un certain nombre de productions et
en même temps être capable de mettre en
oeuvre des politiques imi qui puisse
pour se traduire par des baisses de
charges par de la simplification par une
meilleure organisation il va falloir
nourrir d'ici 2050 deux milliards
d'êtres humains en plus un bel avenir en
perspective pour les agriculteurs
voilà perrine tarneaud et avec nos
penseurs perrine à vos questions à bruno
le maire donc on va se recentrer un peu
sur les questions agricoles justement un
bond à l'invitation de demain déjà
d'aujourd'hui on élargira peut-être un
petit peu à la fin bonsoir bruno le
maire soit des agriculteurs donc
inquiets de leur avenir vous avez pu
rencontrer aujourd'hui au salon de
l'agriculture confrontée à un double
défi à la fois alimentaire et climatique
puisque on leur demande d'alléger leur
empreinte environnementale et puis à la
fois de produire plus parce qu'on est de
plus en plus nombreux sur cette terre
est ce qu'on leur demande trop
aujourd'hui aux agriculteurs
moi je suis convaincu que oui et vous me
permettrez de dire que je trouve votre
au portage très bien fait parce qu'il
rappelle les faits qui sont importants
nous restons la première puissance
agricole européenne contrairement à ce
que je lis ici roulante nous sommes
menacés par une compétition farouche
avec nos voisins en particulier
l'allemagne et en troisième lieu main
tout simplement vous voyez sur ce salon
ne mange pas joe rite aid agriculteurs
ne peuvent plus vivre décemment des
revenus de leur exploitation donc oui il
est temps de prendre un certain nombre
de décisions la france toujours mieux
disantes en matière d'application des
normes environnementales
c'est fini les producteurs doivent
passer avant ils ont besoin de temps ils
ont besoin de capital écosystème d un
peu tard est bien protégé d'écosystèmes
en prenant un petit peu plus de temps
que ce que nous voulons au bout du
compte que nos producteurs disparaissent
des pans entiers de l'agriculture
française sont menacés de disparition
dans la filière troisième pays
consommateur et profite aux salons et et
acier de catalyser tueur mais les
efforts ils les font les paysans ça fait
des années qu'ils les font arrêtons de
demander toujours plus d'efforts à ceux
qui en font déjà depuis des années des
années comprenons leurs difficultés
voyons bien que les trésoreries
aujourd'hui dans les exploitations
requiert porcines aviaires bovine dans
la filière laitière sont totalement à
sec ils peuvent pas faire plus ce qu'est
ce que vous voulez au bout du compte
qu'ils disparaissent ils disparaîtront
très bien qu'est ce qu'on ferait les
affaires qu'est-ce qu'on francs suisses
il y en importeront changer d un temps
hors antilles c'est de la viande ovine
du lait ou des fruits et légumes
réalisées dans d'autres pays avec des
conditions environnementales encore
moins satisfaisante dans cette logique
pour nous finalement c'est pas le bon
choix pour l'agroécologie me paraît un
concept totalement fumeux moi je crois
que le bon cap pour l'agriculture
française c'est produire plus et
produire mieux et c'est en produisant
davantage que les exploitations seront
plus rentables qu'elles pourront dégager
de la marge des profits est donc
respectée mieux les règles
environnementales et davantage soucieux
d'environnement c'est dans ce sens là
qu'il faut prendre les choses je
revendique cette position qui est la
mienne depuis des années qui fait pas
plaisir à tout le monde c'est en
produisant plus qu'on pourra produire
mieux pas l'inversé compris dans des
fermes usines puisqu'on voit qu'il ya
des demandes
d'autorisation pour des exploitations de
plus fermes usines mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces slogans
je vois dans la creuse d'une
exploitation qu'est ce que c'est que ces
slogans mais qu'est ce que l'on veut
regarder dans la creuse et
l'exploitation à qui veut ouvrir
l'agriculture de demain c'est une
agriculture qui respectueuse de
l'environnement la preuve il est les
adieux qui manifestement parce que elle
dégage suffisamment de revenus et de
profits pour investir dans
l'environnement dans la creuse vous avez
une exploitation qui veut faire de
l'engraissement de bétail pour 1000 vaut
bien je vais vous dire je trouve ça
formidable comme projet et je suis
désolé de voir que des as 10 des gens
d'extrême gauche bloc ce projet sur la
base de considérations environnementales
qui sont exagérées avec des inquiétudes
qui sont exagérées qu'est ce que l'on
veut que nos paysans vivent bien et bien
il faut effectivement engraisser nouveau
en france rapatrié la valeur ajoutée en
france permettent à nos exploitations
d'être compétitive car si on continue
dans le chemin qui consiste à pointer du
doigt tout ce que c'est des plus
compétitifs tous ceux qui font des
efforts les exploitations fermeront et
n'auront plus que nos yeux pour pleurer
et dans vos assiettes dans vos assiettes
vous aurez des produits qui ne seront
plus réalisé en france juste pour finir
sur les indices et eu encore des
violences ce week-end à nantes également
à toulouse comment résoudre ces airs qui
risquent de se multiplier ce genre de
projet voit le jour en france par
l'autorité c'est à dire par l'autorité
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi au nom de
quelle légitimité au nom de quel droit d
à dist des représentants de l'extrême
gauche sont ils légitimes 7 juin ils
sont ils légitimes et la seule réponse
c'est l'autorité car je ne vois pas au
nom de quoi il empêcherait un producteur
qui respecte toutes les règles
juridiques qui s'est lancé dans un
projet d'entreprenariat formidable
qu'ils soient bloqués dans son projet
dans la création de richesses qu'il va
faire en les emplois qui va produire par
des gens qui ne représentent qu'eux
mêmes et qui ne respectent ni le droit
ni la république on revient à
l'agriculture avec la fin des quotas
laitiers début avril est ce qu'il faut
craindre bruno le maire cet
environnement totalement libéralisé ou
au contraire en profiter pour s'adapter
augmenter les cheptels et les tailles de
ferme pour le coup je crois qu'il ya un
combat idéologique abonnés qui est
important une partie de l'europe et des
états européens veut un modèle ultra
libéral avec des exploitations
absolument gigantesque cette année dans
leurs agissements dont je parle
concentrés uniquement dans quelques
points du territoire français par
exemple sa production de lait on
fermerait tout le lait dans le sud-ouest
dans d'autres régions pour le garder
uniquement normandie ou dans le nord je
suis totalement opposé à ce type de
projet politique et je pense que la
france va se battre au niveau européen
pour que nous gardions notre modèle
agricole dans lequel peuvent se
développer de grandes exploitations très
compétitive mais où des exploitations de
taille plus modeste avec des produits de
grande qualité des aoc puisse également
continuer à survivre je pense que
l'europe doit changer de ce point de vue
là deux modèles je donne juste un
exemple sur la consommation des produits
locaux moi j'aimerais que dans toutes
les cantines scolaires françaises dans
tous les lieux de consommation publique
on impose une règle simple c'est qu'on
s'approvisionnent en produits réalisés à
moins de 50 km ce qui ce fait de cette
course un an certaines communications
que l'union européenne bloc ce type de
projet au nom d'une idéologie de la
concurrence absolue qu'il faut trouver
le prix le moins cher possible sans
respecter le producteur moi je vais
continuer à me battre pour qu'on
consomme des produits locaux et que l'on
pousse cette consommation de produits
locaux autres difficultés rencontrées
par les agriculteurs français
aujourd'hui les élus liés allende hugo
rue sur les produits agroalimentaires
européens qui touchent directement nos
agriculteurs puisque ces produits
agricoles reflue vers la france et les
cours baissent comment lutter et là sont
complètement démunis norvège le serbe
est jugé pendant un an pour lever
l'embargo russe sur la viande bovine
française et nous avons pu y gagnent
cause avec nicolas sarkozy en discutant
directement d'éclat d'ymir poutine et
bien moi je souhaite que dans les
discussions actuelles qui ont lieu avec
vladimir poutine et avec la russie au
plus haut niveau de l'état car c'est au
plus haut niveau de l'état que ça se
joue on fasse pression sur la russie
pour obtenir la levée de cet embargo il
en va de la survie de milliers de
producteurs bovins en france et de
milliers de producteurs tout court le
marché russe est essentiel pour nous
essentiel pour nos paysans ça doit faire
partie des négociations actuelles avec
la russie jeudi il y aura une des
visites politiques les plus suivis au
salon de l'agriculture c'est celle de
marine le pen elle promet aux campagnes
de relancer les commerces de proximité
de stopper la fermeture des services
publics de rendre à l'agriculture tous
les millions qui vont à bruxelles vous
lui répondez quoi démagogie mensonge
marine le pen ment aux français et
helmond aux paysans français alors dit
on va sortir la politique agricole
commune et ça ira mieux ça ruinera les
paysans français elle leur dit faut
fermer des frontières fermées les
frontières vous ne pourrez plus exporter
un seul produit agricole français ce
sera la ruine de toutes les
exploitations françaises et la chute des
prix donc la chute des revenus ils vont
se reposer osé nous décrire elle le dit
fonctionner il faut multiplier les aides
sociales les services publics qui va
payer ce sont les producteurs eux-mêmes
qui va régler la facture ce sont les
paysans eux-mêmes qui eux vivent de leur
travail et de leurs revenus et pas des
aides sociales marine le pen ment aux
agriculteurs français
elle le revend des illusions
c'est à nous l'ump la droite le centre
d'apporter à tous les paysans français
des réponses qui soit à la fois plus
ferme et plus crédible alors on sort un
petit peu de l'agriculture bruno le
maire je voulais parler d'un amendement
de la loi macron qui permet de modifier
les jour férié ainsi la fin du ramadan
pourrait devenir fériés notamment dans
les départements d'outre-mer al'inverse
des fêtes catholiques ne serait plus
chaud mais est ce que vous êtes pour cet
amendement d'abord je me demande
vraiment ce que cet amendement vient
faire dans la loi macron ça tombe comme
un cheveu sur la soupe c'est d'essence
et oui mais sur le principe ça pose
quand même une réelle difficulté je ne
vois aucune nécessité de toucher
aujourd'hui au calendrier des fêtes
française et je pense que ça
n'appartenant à aucune paix comme je le
souhaite
aucun d'apaisement dans une société qui
en a terriblement besoin je crois que la
responsabilité politique aujourd'hui
s'est posé sur la table les sujets
d'urgence immédiat et ils sont nombreux
le premier d'entre eux c'est le chômage
c'est l'emploi des jeunes ne perdons pas
de temps dans les polémiques stériles
totalement inutile sur le calendrier des
fêtes france et un recul de l'hymne de
l'it et de l'identité c'est sûr fait le
mauvais sujets au mauvais moment c'est
un sujet dont on parle ici au salon sur
le stand de la réunion par exemple je
comprends très bien je dirais au stand
de la réunion par aileurs oui mais ça ne
me paraît pas les sujets à poser sur la
table aujourd'hui et le voir atterrir
comme cela au milieu de nulle part dans
la loi macron je pense que c'est
précisément cette politique dont on ne
veut plus qui polémiquent sur des sujets
qui ne sont pas essentiels et qui évite
soigneusement de traiter les vrais
sujets de difficultés des français
cofinair bruno le maire vous dit vivre
aujourd'hui un des moments politiques
les plus heureux de votre carrière alors
je vous le confirme vous nous confirmez
donc rassurés nous aussi j'imagine que
vous espérez mieux et plus
je peux pas espérer mieux et plus que ce
que je vis actuellement si je peux
garder la même vie libre de conviction
que celle que j'ai aujourd'hui ce sera
formidable temps quel poste quelle place
c'est les français qui le décideront et
pourquoi c'est le moment le plus heureux
finalement de votre carrière politique
parce que je suis totalement libre et
que la liberté n'a pas de prix mais
pourquoi des aviculteurs de savent mieux
que personne les pourquoi est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va aller crescendo en
2016 votre bonheur
parce que je le sens bien comme ça
non mais c'est une intuition mon
intuition depuis 2012 est très simple
depuis 2012 je dis que le système
politique français en train de
s'effondrer sous nos yeux que les
français on ne leur propose pas ce
qu'ils peuvent attendre en termes de
changements politiques c'est mon
intuition depuis 2012 eh bien je suis la
même intuition en me présentant aux
élections à l'ump en allant à la
rencontre des français et on verra
quelles décisions ça me conduit début
2016 ou fin 2000 temps les a presque
deviner au cours de cette émission
parfois nous avons eu quelques
intuitions au cours de cette émission
merci mr debré était avec nous ici au
salon de l'agriculture merci perrine
bonsoir à tous et à très vite
merci